Hales going bros my name is Pippa today
we're going to play three free games for
peds I have some awesome games today
first one is called hot date where you
will date my jock I'm really guessing at
mine yep dad said oh wait why are you
gonna date what's your name I mean it's
Maya so cute
Maya is my top three favorite names you
hear this - amazing yo yo I have a
regional champ just so you know I can
walk the dog all day baby I don't like
your attitude okay what should we write
then my n ask him what he does for fun
I don't know shooting groups props
you're going to tell me yours now aren't
you
like I give a damn I like to Nick people
in their ears neat oh he likes me I'm
over let's meet again yep you did it
Maya I'm proud of you next game is
called and passer what a fantastic name
you play as an egg passer he has come to
an topia and he seeks to earn our favor
and cement they a nice do I control this
finger will I finger people I've said it
I control where my mouse
ah a stranger don't be scared don't be
scared my fellow and friends I am the
ambassador yes I will finger you hell
and faster I will give thee a feast but
mine crater stuck a problem friend there
you go there you go
I am the ambassador hail ambassador but
take it the gate switching ceremony of
course I am the ambassador there it is I
flicked a lot of switches in my days if
you know what I mean alright let's just
go in then well ambassador word of your
good deeds this terrible peace was hard
fought we must seal our new fond
Alliance by common blood I am ready
mother
marry princess Anastasia crying her ass
your queen alright alright alright let's
say well because I am the ambassador
alright alright how do why why is this a
game I don't I look like a penis did I
kill her dammit oh god I killed her too
why do I keep killing everyone I'm sorry
oh my god stop killing her oh my god oh
my god
there it is there it is
[Music]
yes I opposed his Union and thorny anata
Antonio I still remember the scars of
war the destruction this ambassador was
brought upon us can I just kill everyone
he wants gonna kill him and bad such a
power hey yo I did it
well that was [ __ ] easy videogames
videogames videogames videogames
videogames okay so it's solid ha ha ha
oh my god is this I literally controlled
by just moving in a direction yeah yeah
yeah yeah what this is super easy
it's pretty cool huh oh yeah that's how
we do it in Sweden except this is
probably la Manny I don't [ __ ] know
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] pop whip [ __ ]
you up yeah that's what I chopped dick
oh I am I tug like this press two times
on the ones with haircuts one time for
the Nazis left and right for the girl
one two three one two three one two oh
oh oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] for breakfast no I don't
don't tell my CI spot damn it
okay the one light strike come well
that's fine I got this [ __ ] huh yeah
Sarita I can't
meatballs that's all I got [ __ ] yes I
finally transcended my human form to
become good at video games at this [ __ ]
oh look at that [ __ ] bar no no I was so
close that was [ __ ] awesome bro so if
you enjoyed this video now it's a great
time to leave it like it helps me out a
lot to support me and if you like my
videos it helps alright thank you both
so much for watching as always leave a
comment about what shoes you're wearing
and I'll see you a stay awesome brother
okay you know why is is so creepy
Prince's exile ah